I think we're now ready to learn a
little bit about the dark reactions but
just to remember where we are in this
whole scheme of photosynthesis photons
came in and excited electrons and
chlorophyll in the light reactions and
as those photons went to lower and lower
energy states we saw it over here in the
last video as they went to lower and
lower energy states and all of this was
going on in the thylakoid membrane right
over here you could imagine let me do it
in a different color you can imagine it
occurring right here is they went into
lower and lower energy states two things
happen one the release of energy was
able to pump the hydrogen's across this
membrane and then when you had a high
concentration of hydrogen's here those
went back through the ATP synthase and
drove that motor to produce ATP and then
the final electron acceptor or a
hydrogen acceptor depending on how you
want to view it the whole hydrogen atom
was nad plus so the two byproducts or
the two byproducts that we're going to
continue using in photosynthesis from
our light cycle from our light reactions
I guess I shouldn't call it the light
cycle were I wrote it up here ATP and
NADPH and then the byproduct was is that
we needed an electron to replace that
first excited electron so we take it
away from water and so we also produce
oxygen which is a very valuable
byproduct of this reaction but now that
we have this ATP and this NADPH we're
ready to proceed into the dark reactions
and I want to highlight again even
though it's called the dark reactions it
doesn't mean that it happens at night it
actually happens at the same time as the
light reactions it occurs while the Sun
is out the reason why they call it the
dark reactions is that they're light
independent they don't require photons
they only require ATP NADPH and carbon
dioxide so let's understand what's going
on here a little bit better so let me
down to where I have some clean space
down here so we had our light reactions
light reactions and they produced I just
reviewed this
produced some ATP and produce some na
dhih pH and now we're going to take some
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere and
all of this will go into the alcohol the
light independent reactions because dark
reactions is misleading so the light
independent independent reactions the
actual the actual mechanism is called
the Calvin cycle and then we're going to
that's what this video is really about
goes into the Calvin cycle and out pops
and out will pop whether you want to
call it P gal we talked about in the
first video or g3p this is
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate this is
phospho glyceraldehyde they are the
exact same molecule just different names
and you can imagine it as a three carbon
chain with a phosphate group with a
phosphate group and then this can then
be used to build other carbohydrates you
put two of these together you can get a
glucose you might remember in the first
stage of glycolysis or the first time
that we cut a glucose molecule we ended
up with two phosphoglyceraldehyde
molecules glucose has six carbons this
has three let's study the calvin cycle
in a little bit in just a little bit
more detail so let's say exiting the
light reactions let me write this well
I'll keep that there so exiting the
light reactions let's say we have well
let's start off with six carbon dioxide
so this is independent of the car with
the light reactions and I'll show you
why I'm using these numbers I don't have
to use these exact numbers so let's say
I start off with six co2 s and I could
write a co2 because we really care about
what's happening with the carbon we can
just write it as a you know a single
carbon has two oxygens on it which I
could drop but I'm not going to draw
them right now because I want to really
show you what happens to the carbons
maybe I should draw this in this yellow
just to show only the carbons I'm not
showing you the oxygens on here and
happens is the co2 the co2 the six co2 s
essentially react with and I'll talk a
little bit about this reaction in a
second they react with six molecules six
molecules and this is going to look a
little bit strange to you of this
molecule you could call it our you be P
that's short for ribulose biphosphate
sometimes called ribulose one five by
phosphate and the reason why it's called
that is because it's a five carbon it's
a five carbon molecule so three four
five and it has a phosphate on the one
and five carbons so it's ribulose by
phosphate or sometimes rob you Lowe's
one let me write this one that's the
first carbon 5 by phosphate we have two
phosphates so that's ribulose one five
by phosphate fancy name but it's just a
five carbon chain with two phosphates on
it these two react together and this is
a this is a simplification these two
react together there's a lot more going
on here but I want you to get the big
picture to form to form 12 molecules 12
molecules of P gal of
phosphoglyceraldehyde or
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate of P of P gal
which you can view as a it has three
carbons and then it has a phosphate
group it has a phosphate group and just
to make sure we're counting for our
carbons properly let's think about what
happens we have 12 of these guys so we
can think of it that we have 12 times 3
we have 36 carbons
now did we start with 36 carbons well we
have 6 times 5 carbons that's 30 plus
another 6 here so yes we have 36 carbons
they react with each other to form this
P gal now this the this the bonds or the
electrons in this molecule are in a
higher energy state than the bot then
the electrons in this molecule so we
have to add energy in order for this
reaction to happen
this won't happen spontaneously and the
energy for this reaction the enter if we
use the numbers 6 & 6 here the energy
for this reaction is going to come from
12 ATP's
12 ATP so you could imagine two ATP's
for every carbon in every ribulose
biphosphate and 12 nadh --is + 12 na
dphh I should say I don't wanna get you
confused with it's very similar to NADH
but I want to get you confused with what
goes on in respiration and then these
leave as 12a DPS
a DPS plus 12 phosphate groups and then
you're going to have plus 12 na dhih
nadp+ --is and the reason why this is a
source of energy is because the
electrons in NADPH or you can say the
hydrogen with the electron in NADPH is
at a higher energy state so as it goes
to a lower energy state it helps drive a
reaction and of course ATP's
when they lose their phosphate groups
those electrons in a very high energy
state they enter a lower energy State
help drive a reaction help put energy
into reaction so then we have these 12 P
gals now the reason why it's called a
Calvin cycle as you can imagine we
studied the krebs cycle cycles we start
reusing things the reason why it's
called the calvin cycle is because we do
reuse actually most of these pee gals so
of the 12 P gals we're going to use ten
of them we're going to use ten of them
to let me actually let me do it this way
so we're going to have 10 P gals 10
phosphoglyceraldehyde x' 10 P gals we're
going to use to recreate the ribulose
biphosphate and the counting works
because we have 10 3 carbon molecules
that's 30 carbons then we have 6 5
carbon molecules 30 carbons but this
once again is going to take energy this
is going to take the energy from 6 ATP's
so you're going to have 6 atps
essentially losing their phosphate group
the electrons enter lower energy states
drive reaction
you're going to have six a DPS plus six
phosphate groups that get released and
so you see it is a cycle but no the
question is well you know Angie I used
all of these what do I get out of it
well I only use 10 out of the 12 so I
have to pee gals left to pee gals left
and these can then be used and the
reason why I used six and six is so that
I get twelve here and I get two here and
the reason why I have two years because
to pee gals can be used to make a
glucose to make a glucose which is a six
six carbon molecule it's small its
formula we've seen it for c6h12o6 but
it's important to memorize to remember
that doesn't have to just be glucose it
could then go off and generate longer
change carbohydrates and and and start
to anything that has a carbon backbone
so this is it this is the dark reaction
we were able to take the byproducts the
byproduct of the light reactions with
the ATP and the NADH is there's some
more ATP there and use it to fix carbon
this is called carbon fixation when you
take carbon in a gaseous form and you
put it into a solid structure that is
called carbon fixation
so through this Calvin cycle we were
able to fix carbon and the energy comes
from these molecules generated from the
light reaction and of course it's called
a cycle because we generate these pee
gals some of them can be used to
actually produce glucose or other
carbohydrates while most of them
continue on to be recycled into ribulose
biphosphate which once again reacts with
carbon dioxide and then you get the
cycle happening over and over again now
we said it doesn't happen in a in a
vacuum actually if you want to know the
actual location where this is occurring
this is all occurring in the stroma in
the fluid inside the chloroplast but
outside of your thylakoid so in your
stroma this is where your dot light
independent reactions are actually
occurring and it's not just happening
it's not just happening with the ATP and
NADPH there's actually a fairly
decent-sized
enzyme or protein that's facilitating it
that's allowing the carbon dioxide to
bond it's ER
points and the ribulose biphosphate and
then the ATP to react at certain points
to essentially drive these two guys to
react together and that enzyme that
enzyme sometimes it's called Rubisco
I'll tell you why it's called Rubisco so
this is Rubisco so rube I mean I get the
capitalisation right ribulose by
phosphate ooh
this co carboxylase and this is what it
looks like so it's a pretty big protein
enzyme molecule but you can imagine that
you have your ribulose biphosphate
bonding at one point you have your
carbon dioxide bonding at another point
I don't know what points they are ATP a
bonds at another point it reacts that
that makes this thing twist and turn in
certain ways to make the ribulose
biphosphate react with the carbon
dioxide NADPH might be reacting at other
parts and that's what facilitates this
entire calvin cycle and you might you
know we we know we I told you over here
that this rubp this is ribulose 1/5 by
phosphate this Rubisco this is short for
ribulose 1/5 by phosphate carboxylase i
won't write it all out you could look it
up but it's just telling you look i'm
i'm it's it's an enzyme that's used to
react carbon and ribulose 1/5 by
phosphate but now we're done we're done
with photosynthesis we were able to
start off with photons and water to
produce ATP and nadph because we had
that those excited electrons we had the
whole chemiosmosis to drive the that
allowed the ATP synthase to produce ATP
NADPH was the final electron acceptor
these are then used as the fuel in the
calvin cycle in the dark reaction which
is badly named it should be called the
light independent reaction because it
actually does happen in the light you
take your fuel from the light reactions
with some carbon dioxide and you can fix
it using your I like to call it the
Rubisco enzyme in the calvin cycle and
you end up with your phospho
glyceraldehyde which could also be
called your glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
which can then be used to generate
glucose
which we all use to eat and and fuel our
bodies or any we learn in cellular
respiration that can then be converted
into ATP when we need it